you guys WWDC is gonna be here before we
know it I'm so excited it's next week
it's gonna be here so so soon and when
that comes more rumors and one of the
big things obviously that they talk
about at WDC because it is a Developers
Conference is software so iOS 13 is
gonna be the next release of iOS and the
thing that I'm most excited about is
dark mode all of the apps that we have
especially Mojave now with their dark
mode update it's been a long time coming
that iOS needs to have this option what
I have actually set up I will do a
triple click and just like inverts all
the colors it's like fake dark mode so
will triple click and it takes us back
to normal but an actual dark mode is
something that is it's gotta be it has
to be there are some screen shot leaks
we have over here so here it is dark
mode iOS 13 will include a dark mode for
the first time I remember when they
originally announced Mojave with dark
mode that was a huge deal and I don't
think I've ever turned it off I've had
dark mode on since I installed it let's
take a look and see what else MacRumors
is rounding up here always have such
great roundups so the first thing
obviously was dark mode here are some
leaked screenshots home screen will look
similar to home screen light both at the
dock will be darker updated volume
control that is so something that they
should have done a long time ago it
always tries me crazy because the volume
is over top of whatever it is that
you're watching so that takes up so much
screen real estate Oh iPad tweaks this
is something that I'm excited about
there to be improving the multitasking
and actually this is down here here it
is Mouse support on iPad pro you would
think that's something that they already
had by now I mean the I've had Pro is
really powerful so this will be just
make it even more powerful so that's
exciting new gestures iPads are expected
to gain new on do gestures for text
input cross-platform iOS and Mac apps oh
this is interesting to messages will be
more like whatsapp so you have like a
profile in a picture and new Find My
iPhone app how many times have you guys
my My iPhone app just I would like to
see a show of hands you could put your
hand raises in the comments below I have
used it so many times I use my Apple
watch so wait times throughout the day
to find my iphone it says it's working
on an all-new app thick vines find my
friends and find my phone into one the
app is expected to be called to find my
which will include a new find Network
feature be tracked down even when not
packaged by our silo I leveraging other
nearby devices that is actually really
really incredible what that means is if
your phone is in airplane mode or not
even connected to Wi-Fi or cellular
you'll be able to find it
my sister had her laptop stolen it was
in the airport and she was getting a
massage at one of those like Airport
massage kiosks and somebody just came
down swiped it we tried to get security
footage but nothing ever really came of
it unfortunately what this means is if
you do lose something like that and it
is locked and it's not connected to
Wi-Fi using other devices around it
you'll be able to find that missing item
it would be interesting if somehow Apple
ends up buying tile if you guys are
familiar with child I did a video on
this so long ago but I have tiles in all
of my things all of my backpacks all of
my luggages suitcases everything
the only downside to tile is it's not
GPS but it does rely on its network of
other tile users so if using bluetooth
they're all constantly connecting to
each other so if you do market item as
loss that item that goes into lost mode
and that is continually pinging looking
for other tiles around it to help you
locate that lost item so I feel like
that's something that Apple is I mean it
it's so easy to do so that would mean
that if Bluetooth or something isn't on
on your phone but it is lost when you
put it into loss mode Bluetooth is
automatically turned on and then it's
constantly using other devices to find
your lost phone
I like this oh well I kept reading the
article it said Apple's also said to be
working on a related hardware product
described as a
like item tracker Oh
like this you could attach it to any
item and perdu any users iCloud there's
no word when Adam might debut this
accessory and it could cover the fall
along as I do my phone's updated maps
updated reminders books home health the
health app will feature an improved view
of daily activities a more comprehensive
tracking of menstrual cycles I wonder if
they have like an option you can share
your cycle with your friends I mean I
don't know I think that would be useful
in some cases
I don't think about it speed
enhancements keyboard fonts updated
share sheets what's a share sheet is the
shared without it with a share shoot
sharing photos and weblinks training
time a new feature limiting kids can and
can't contract this is David I like that
revamp file app they definitely need
everything file up middle emojis
flamingo our waffle sloth white heart
people holding hands Ice Cube snorkel
orangutan juice box falafel and more
what the heck is that
thank you guys for watching I just want
to talk a little bit about some of the
iOS 13 updates that I saw because I'm
gonna be so excited for WWC it's gonna
be here so soon I will be there shortly
following me on Twitter and Instagram
because that's probably posting most of
my first updates and then of course in
YouTube videos so be sure to subscribe
and hit the bell so you'll be alerted
when I do post some new videos and I
think that's it let me know what's the
one thing on iOS think you guys are
looking for also what are you looking
forward to at WWDC what do you think
they're gonna announce I'll be probably
making a follow-up video talking about
some double WC predictions but for now
I'm gonna go and have a see you guys in
the next video
[Music]